[Music]
so
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and if you're seeing this that means
everything went right if you're not
seeing this then i'm screaming in rage
incoherently because i didn't get my
ipad to set up correctly and record this
properly and i lost all the footage and
i am currently crying and screaming
and tearing apart every chair in sight
but if you are seeing this hi welcome to
solar smash so this really combines two
of my favorite things
space and absolute utter destruction of
everyone that i've ever known and the
entire earth will be subjugated
and crushed under my heel and those are
my two favorite things
so this is just basically you know that
game that i played about the
the the dudes and the
oh don't kill me now you know that game
uh it's not like really like that or at
least i don't think so it's
basically kind of like a sandbox
destruction so whereas that one was
people this is
not now so uh hey wow
oh oh oh look at that can i zoom out oh
my goodness
oh god that's pretty
it's very pretty god i hate that i'm
going to destroy it but that's
very pretty so like in simcity you know
when you build your city and then you're
done with your city and then you cause a
bunch of destruction
a bunch of disasters that's kind of what
we have here oh my god
oh my god wait what is it what does all
the buttons do i got to figure out what
i'm oh
yes screenshot mode oh my god it's so
pretty
god i love space so much
god is so pretty yeah destruction uh say
goodbye to this earth you know we gave
it a good try
what does this do what does this do
oh no wait stop i didn't know that
oh no
well might as well keep going
i'm out of bullets why am i out of
bullets am i out of bullets
oh no i oh
um i feel like there would be a lot more
complete destruction if uh if there was
now a um
a uh a giant hole in the middle of the
planet
you know i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
criticize it because i just killed
everyone on earth
if they if they can hang on for a little
bit longer i guess you know more power
to them
oh and the way the gloves spit oopsies
didn't know that
did that sorry
brazil so i didn't mean to do that
what i'm meant to do what does this do
oh
like a time lapse why does that matter
slow motion
that's pretty cool i guess okay that's
pretty cool anyway uh
not what i meant to do kind of starting
out with baby steps here i don't like to
go whole hog right off the bat i know
some people probably would just like to
wreak havoc and
send people to hell as fast as possible
but personally i actually like to um
i like to i don't like to make people
suffer with the slowness of their
agonizing death i just
you know i it's a game so i just want to
figure out what what exactly oh god
well that wasn't nearly as impactful as
well kind of spread i guess
do you make him bigger than that i'll
just do oh it's just
it's a shotgun of of asteroids
oh no i meant oh oh you can touch a lot
more i've only killed 317 million people
i
feel like it's might be more than that i
feel like
maybe the whole you know hole in the
planet
that's kind of i didn't mean to turn
earth into a fleshlight
like i didn't want to do that um
oh god why is it still why is it i'm
trying to spit i'm
trying
i sincerely am trying
to simply turn
the planet and i don't know
how do you unselect if you
no you still do the throwing
how do you not do this no don't reset
the planet reset my finger
oh you gotta touch outside the planet
okay that makes sense i didn't do that
all right what about if i bomb
antarctica that's got to be
at least a little bit better okay
this is a picture of the moon and it's i
think it's implying that i'm about to
send the moon to crash into earth which
is
dope i've done that in uh universe
sandbox but
just unsure oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh
it's not gonna pop out the other oh
well we gotta send it through to the
other side can i send a few
i send multiple i can't oh no i can't oh
no
uh well earth you're about to get a
pounding um
oh no i see the ball oh there she go
there she goes
god no santa santa's
dead i killed santa
what have i done well it can't be on the
naughty list cause he's dead
anyway seven only 728 million people are
dead still seven billion people on this
planet humans are resilient you know you
gotta give them that they are resilient
even though the
the molten core of the earth is exposed
and rapidly
cooling and most likely collapsing in on
itself it's still fine
however this looks like a black hole and
you know
i'm not a hundred percent sure what
oh
no oh
that's fine there went africa that
didn't quite do what i
thought it was gonna do i mean i don't
know exactly what i thought a black hole
was gonna do but you know
i thought it might have been you know a
bigger black hole it was kind of
underwhelming about the black hole what
about multiple
what about multiple
[Music]
well now everyone's dead why is everyone
dead now why did that kill
why am i upset why did that kill
everyone golly
oh oh oh
there's nothing left what is lightning
gonna do
oh my god
[Music]
that wasn't lightning
good god all right thor
throwing a bit of a temper tantrum
you're not gonna have much left oh wow
that's sad
that's really sad you hate to see it boy
how do you hate to see it but ain't that
cool that's pretty dope
okay i think we need a new plant ooh
i love it it's boreous more like snorius
what's glorious what is this
ah some kind of ice world what is this
garbage who cares about boris it's
probably some sci-fi thing that i don't
know about
and i probably look bad but that's okay
we got more uh
toys to play with now i don't know if
anyone actually is here actually it says
there's no people here so this
this wouldn't be satisfying to destroy
because there's no
human lives to ruin
it's just a game fun game mars well
there's no one on mars let's get
terraformed mars
which is dope the idea of this is super
cool
i love this i love it i almost don't
want to destroy it
three billion man if we could get ah if
we could terraform mars and it could be
beautiful like this and blue and green
and oh
and then i destroy it i can't i'm sorry
guys i can't i cannot destroy
like terraform mars is just such a cool
idea
like 3 billion people living on mars
you know it's just like so fascinating
to me that
i can't do it i love it too much putting
at least put in some like sappy
sentimental music because i
literally cannot destroy terraform mars
because the dream
needs to stay alive earth i'll blast it
out of existence 10 ways from sunday
but terraformed mars like just the
idea of us traveling all the way to mars
going through
all of the immense hardships of trying
to even build a colony out there
just getting it started is probably
taking hundreds of years
multiple generations just to get it
started for a
chance a chance at terraforming it and
terraforming it alone would be an
unimaginable feat of
impossible geoengineering and then if
someone comes along and blows earth to
hell
with weird lightning storms and black
holes and rogue moons
you know then we have a backup plan so
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do it
i can't do it i love you i love you
let's try not to touch up oh god there's
so much to touch
i will not touch you i just wanted to
get a close look
i my fingers are death my fingers are
death
i think that might be olympus mons oh
the great
scar looks like job of the hut i love it
[Music]
i love it i don't even know if it's like
feasible to ever do this i i never want
to say that something's impossible
because
man if enough people dream it maybe it
is
i could never i could never i would
never i would never no we need another
planet
like give me another earth what do we
got wait do people live on hades no
boring persephone okay persephone who
get
purple [ __ ] get out of here who cares
about you persephone
what are you doing here purse perseph
you've got more people than
earth did 8.651 billion
more like not that number ew
14 million
i don't know what kind of weapon i have
but man it is potent
all right uh [ __ ] this island in
particular
with missiles
[Music]
not enough damn
oh my god oh my god what does this do
oh my god i am so sorry persephone
oh god persephone
i'm really sorry about that one holy
[ __ ]
uh it's pac-man it's it's nice
lips really nice lips man there's
those are some smooching lips and let's
get some
uh let's get
[Music]
go horrible yeah well not that bad
well maybe hey you know persephone you
ain't looking so bad
kind of got that glazed over dead
expression but those lips
luscious smooth that and perfect
kind of ruined it a little bit but still
hey wow you know what you need
eyebrows
perfect i love you
what does this do oh
nice piercing hey persephone i love
that hey let me pop that zit for you
there
oh it's fine it's okay i thought that
was gonna be much worse than
oh wow
oh well lovely nose you've got there let
me just
smooth that out there real quick
not exactly smooth you know these nose
jobs never actually work out too well ah
there we go
what does this button do
oh
okay not so bad oh oh no
oh no
hey two stars that's pretty cool well
persephone is not doing so good
there's a little bit of atmosphere left
i see that so i haven't burnt it all off
what happens if i just like
a bunch of these bombs i blast
persephone's ass with a ass load of
bombs
oh man i gotta get them so they're gonna
chain right
i'm bored let's do it
well that was a lot less than i thought
it would be i thought the whole planet
was gonna go kaboom how do i make the
whole planet go kaboom
machine world 812 million are these just
robos are these that's not fun
i don't want to kill anything that
doesn't have a soul in it or custom
planet oh man that looks horrible man
that's awful
that's really bad you should be ashamed
of yourself did anybody live here
god i hope not anyway let's go back to
earth
let me go back to i'm not going to
destroy it but i just love the look of
terraform mars
like just imagine imagine i know i
played this
uh played with this in like universe
sandbox but just imagine like it's it's
this is what mars is now
just a cold dry desert well what if it
could be more
like what if it could be i think there's
every reason to believe there's
water on mars maybe not as much as on
earth
i don't know i don't know what the the
distribution of elements is across
the other planets but you know just
imagine if it
actually happened it won't happen in my
lifetime i know
i'm not gonna live to see it i know i'm
not but maybe if i could just
if i could do anything to set the path
towards this that would
i could die a happy man anyway let's
blow up some
[ __ ] here earth yeah get out of here
earth what are you an [ __ ] yes
all right what is this oh it's like the
aliens from where's
washington dc go get em buddy
get em hey
you shot it down well
all right you're already basically dead
so whoa
crazy that's pretty cool
hey i'm not gonna lie that's pretty cool
uh you might want a duck
holy [ __ ]
what the hell was that thing that was
number two
oh my god what's happening oh god what
the hell
the cork blue
god damn damn son
where'd you find that okay what else can
these do
go for it sorry washington
where is it hello
hello oh there it is it's teensy it's
teensy tiny
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do you're so cute what are you gonna do
you ain't gonna do nothing you ain't
gonna do nothing
you're not gonna do nothing oh
look at you uh oh
wait wait
what oh oh oh
oh oh no
australia look out oh no australian
airpods
africa look out look out
look out oh well is it trying to cut the
earth in half
is it trying to cut the earth in half i
refuse to believe only
500 million people have died from this
are you trying to cut the earth in half
are you going to succeed
oh my god you still oh you are cutting
the earth
in half i'll just let you go then
man the sun don't look so good yeah i
guess carry on
um great job
keep it up good work uh i believe in you
so oh there's the sound
oh the lovely sound of the earth being
sliced in
twain i'm kind of curious as to what the
objective is like if an alien species
had the power to cut the earth in half
and wanted to
what would be the gain from it do they
want the core is there like peeling it
like an apple and they're gonna
grab the metal core and they're just
gonna run away with it because i feel
like they could have done that
with like say venus no one really cares
about venus or uh
mercury you can just take mercury that
that that plants
basically just like it's gone anyway
just go ahead and take it
but uh earth and mars you know all the
ones farther out just leave those behind
for us we
we have use for those funny the way the
clouds kind of move straight
in and out of the the uh i'm gonna call
that the death canyon
the grander canyon the even better
canyon did that cross over where the
oh it did it did cross over where the
grand canyon was
it's just the grand canyon got a little
grander nothing really to worry about
there
are you done no you're not done my god
all right you know what i'm patient i
can wait
[Music]
okay i've officially run out of patience
um where's my laser i know i have a
laser here
here let me help you with this let me
help you
is this helping am i actually doing
anything
[Music]
i fired a thousand weapons you know it
doesn't feel like it
oh no oh no look out look out
look out oh no oh they're fine our job's
almost done here job's almost done
hey you're not done not leaving me with
the rest of it i see
all right fine then get the get the
atlas pillars left
okay and uh the earth is apparently fine
from that
[Music]
yeah that'll buff out oh that's
survivable yeah um
okay so that's that took a little longer
than i thought it would but everyone's
still alive we're still
good i'm assuming that the earth would
just you know kind of float like that it
wouldn't
come back together or anything none of
the lava would come shooting out and the
whole structure of the crush wouldn't
collapse or anything like that so i
think we're all good there that makes
sense that checks out
uh now with that let's find out what's
up with this
from here it's perfect that's
big or small big small small big big
it's big it's big
that's big what do you want how can we
help you
selling alien girls girl scout cookies
nope oh
bye okay see ya oh boy hey
uh well it's gonna be easy when you get
to the middle
and peekaboo oh bye boy
okay uh i hope you we got something from
that dude
because i think we lost out on this
bargain but uh later
uh nerd what does this do it's a shield
or something to finally protect this
planet from the horrors of
whatever the hell we're trying to
subject it to don't worry earth
protection is on the way oh it is a
shield
this is shield there's no way that i
could penetrate that shield
[Music]
ah sick sick
no way oh that's epic nothing's getting
through there
not even this mega missile maybe the
mega missile i don't know
we'll find out about the mega missile
nothing not a scratch
not a oh no not a not a screw not a
scratch
not a scratch oh [ __ ] we're fine well
there's
many people dead but oh we're back
oh [ __ ] that is a tough son of a [ __ ]
oh what is this
why can't i hear you in the vacuum of
space oh god
good it's it's like uh it's subnautica
but space
horrible god what if we just saw that
one day
god what if we all looked up and we just
saw this ginormous worm snaking through
this
guy no please stay away shield protect
us
oh shield protected us well damn it's
too bad there's two
three four
man space is pretty noisy
jesus this is this is horrible this is
terrible awful i hate it it is so much
but also i love it i love it but i hate
it but i love it but i hate it is this
god in the bottom there is it supposed
to be
oh no no
oh lord she common
oh oh nothing we could do there'd be
nothing we could do
that'd be nothing what if that just
happened someday i mean there's no way
there's no way something like that would
never be able to exist
no living thing but an artificial
construction maybe
but even so it's there's no way
oh yeah make yourself at home hey come
on in hey don't worry about it
it's all good hey kick up your uh
oh wow uh hungry growing boys you know
oh boy oh
look at that oh you're done oh you got
your fill you know
you could have gone literally any of the
other planets uh what is this
cosmological horror and uh
how is it going to subject south america
to its what is the happening
oh no
oh no oh no oh let it go
no there goes south america did i say
south africa i don't remember
oh god no jeez
that is nightmare oh that's so nightmare
what are you going to do against the
shield
yeah you ain't got nothing against the
shield oh
nothing you got nothing on the shield
you can't
you can't ah you can't uh get out of
here
okay all right here we go god all right
oh my god oh oh wow yeah uh-huh
uh no not the punt oh
well now i need to see that punch on a
normal earth let me reset the planet
here
in slow motion can you just give
america a good old high five fist bumpy
punchy lunch
you just punch lunch that let's get to
the punch
here we go all right slow down there
buddy all right i'm ready i want to see
the
i want to see earth heart
kind of pitiful you know kind of
pathetic
i'm not going to lie that's kind well oh
how deep did that go
oh
oh kind of pitiful you know i'm not
gonna
uh okay so uh
yeah round two on the punch
come on dude punch it come on
punch it it's just some guys it's like
god it comes to our solar system and
it's just angry you know like you punch
a wall but you're like
can't believe the stacy god didn't go to
god prom with me and then
this happened i think i did it i don't
know what i did exactly
but i did it
[Music]
can you do this
she's fine that'll buff out oh no
she's uh
[Music]
oh she's not fine oh
oh i didn't know you could do that wait
what about that the two
i wonder if it'll blow up the other one
oh there she go
damn who knows who knew the sun was so
fragile
[Music]
oh what was that hello
oh yeah
and there she go just goes to show that
no one should have this kind of power
what does this do
1.7 what does this mean it's like a
power meter
oh no i can make the punch stronger
let's get destructo punch in here oh no
you can't make the punch
wha what would happen if this was more
powerful it already blew up the place
was it oh hey bud you got here quick
are you the same one that did the shield
nice horn dude
yeah it seems like it you know it's like
the same thing you did
before all right well
there you have it but if this is more
powerful
feed me seymour well that is a
smash system hey there's still 429
million people living we're fine
this is good this is great
uh yeah i'm gonna end it on uh terraform
mars
i'm not gonna destroy it i'm not it's
not one of those things where i'm gonna
save it
and destroy it last because really
honestly like it's it's a beautiful
thing
sometimes you can't just destroy
everything because if you destroy
everything
then you don't have anything in the
future and isn't that a life lesson for
us
all yeah pretty cool anyway this is on
uh mobile devices so ios or android um
if you want to get it for yourself
uh very fun it's nice a little sandbox a
lot of ways to get the aggression out
but also a lot of ways to look forward
to the future
not my future i'll be dead but maybe i
can die on mars
man can dream so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want me to die
on mars leave a like
leave a like if you hope beyond hope
that markiplier dies on mars
wrote a comment that you'll write on my
grave
on mars whatever really speaks to your
soul about my
dead body on mars commemorate it
in the future so that i won't i won't
know but i'll be dead
but people will know that i was there
and died and that's all that matters
so thank you and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you